hey folks
welcome to this test of the audio visual
system associated with the dark horse
podcast which will be live in just a few
minutes
we are just doing our usual check to see
whether the audio and video are
in sync whether or not the amplitude is
correct for you to hear it
on your system and whether everything is
good to go so please tell us in the chat
whether things
seem copacetic do they seem copacetic
if you feel good about what you've seen
they're probably copacetic
all right we've got feedback we'll see
in a few minutes
so
so
so
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream
number 49 is that right that's right
for today we are perfectly square we are
very square we're always a little square
but
um so in the audio visual check before
the podcast we always do a little check
just to make sure the equipment is
working
and somebody in the chat said they could
hear me
and see me but wanted to know if it was
normal that they could
smell me and i wanted to just take a
moment to respond and say no
it's very unlikely you could smell me
but probably you're having
a stroke so you might want to look into
that
or if you're luckier you're having a
synesthetic experience
and uh keep up with it oh synthetic it
could be the mushrooms kicking in mm-hmm
or just your brain or just your brain
right
exactly okay well cool so
um where should we begin today well we
want to talk about a number of things we
want to talk about
the political compass test we want to
talk about complex systems
and both mesentery and helium obviously
obviously
and uh we want to talk a little bit
about sultanates yes um and probably
other things as well
uh should we start with political
compass test let's start with the
political compass test
okay uh do you want to begin by just
describing what you understand it to be
sure um political compass test if you
went way back in my
twitter feed a couple years ago you
would find me saying something like
you didn't want to engage the modern era
politically without at least running
through the political compass test
because it adds a dimensionality to the
ability to
understand people's political position
that
isn't there in the classic right left
dimension so if you imagine
a system of two axes the left right axis
is the same as normal political left and
political right but there's a second
axis the vertical axis that goes
from libertarian in the bottom up
to authoritarian in the top and the idea
is that this gives you four quadrants
that describe different sorts of
political
ideologies right so it's a small l
libertarian this is not a map
for um the big l libertarian political
party that we have in the united states
for instance
yes and in fact uh if you look on
my wikipedia page you will see that i am
quoted as describing myself
as a left libertarian which is sort of a
head scratcher
if you think of it as big libertarian
but it is of course little libertarian
which means
uh very liberty focused um as opposed to
trying to dictate how things ought to be
uh one one way i've heard it described
is the libertarian versus
authoritarian access is that those
near the authoritarian end uh prefer to
use power to accomplish their goals
and those closer to the libertarian and
prefer to use
reason or perhaps gentler forms of
coercion
so you know given that you might imagine
that politicians people who have decided
that they want to be in a position
of of power would lean towards the
authoritarian end
of the axis simply because they have
chosen uh to
to be in a position in which they hope
to exert some control
in many cases to to try to do good uh
but that
but that power is inherently part of the
job description
well i want to i want to back us up just
slightly because
my sense is that it's not that um
libertarians like
uh gentler forms of coercion i believe
the bias really if you
if you uh chase down what we actually
believe is you want to minimize
the coercion necessary to accomplish the
objective
which is why the power versus reason
description seems just too
too much in favor of the libertarian end
for me to say it without any
qualification
qualifying words at all because it seems
like
you know that must be my bias showing um
but it i think it is pretty accurate
frankly well let me uh i think where it
goes
would be something like this for me at
least i will say
the mechanisms i favor most to
accomplish an objective like leveling a
playing field
would be um incentives
that allow the market to solve problems
right now i am not
a market fundamentalist i don't believe
that the market inherently solves all of
our problems if we just
give it leeway i actually think we need
to very carefully think about what
incentives
um to place but once we place those
incentives
market mechanisms allow people
essentially to discover whether they
are on the right track by whether or not
it rewards them again this is not the
system we have lots of people get paid
for doing terrible things to society
and that shouldn't be but a system of
proper incentives would be a very gentle
way to
get society to function better than it
does yes
so the the people who made the political
compass test
um decades ago at this point have um
have taken a lot of flack for it uh and
have also responded
um almost entirely as far as i can tell
with with careful
nuanced discussion of what it is that
they're doing uh so
you can go online and take the test
yourself and it will
plot you on this on this graph of two
axes and then it will also show you
who among historical figures both past
and present you
are like and unlike and uh you know
for for reasons of a little bit more
diving deep into the final chapter of
our book i went back and
took it again recently this week and was
noodling around on their site
and found some of these charts that they
have in which they have plotted
current his current uh political figures
on so
i want before we show this so this is uh
we're going to show
a graph the political compass test graph
of
their estimations of where
the the candidates for president
in 2020 in the united states show up on
the
graph all of them not just the two major
party candidates but all the democrats
who are running the republicans the
green
the and the libertarian um so how do
they you know how do they get these do
they get these politicians to take these
tests no
uh and maybe some of them do um but
their position is and i'll just read
here from their site you don't have to
show this sack
um and they're on their faq
page how can you determine where
politicians are honestly at without
asking them and you know before i even
read their answer i would say
as an animal behaviorist i used to joke
oh wouldn't it be easier if we could
just interview the bees or the beavers
or
the parakeets like no actually because
they'd lie yeah
would politicians lie of course they
would you know of course they would
so what they say here is how can you
tell where they are honestly at by
asking them
especially around election time we rely
on reports parliamentary voting records
manifestos
and actions that speak much louder than
words it takes a great deal longer than
simply having the politician take the
test
but it's also a far more accurate
assessment okay so they go on a bit but
given that um let us
show zach the political compass tests
estimation
of where in 2020 the u.s
candidates for president fall on their
graph
left is left right is right top is
authoritarian bottom is libertarian oof
right almost everyone who was running
for president
in the united states this year shows up
in the authoritarian right
trump of course pence of course biden
yeah
not really that much farther left than
trump and only a couple squares down in
the authoritarian axis
harris a similar position to biden as
biden as to trump
almost everyone else the the big
exceptions and
i was so pleased to see this gabbard
tulsi gabbard and then we have hawkins
as the green candidate
uh over over on in the left
libertarian camp and joe jorgensen who's
the
libertarian candidate for president far
far right
in in libertarian camp and
sanders and gravel also and left
libertarian
so i want to point out a couple of
things here i have to say
i both do and don't buy this graph and
the reason
is that i am afraid that what we are
seeing is
downstream of the effect of a giant
magnetic force yeah and what that but
that wouldn't we
that wouldn't mean that this was untrue
it would just mean that these characters
don't necessarily have the agency that
they pretend they do or think they do
well i think i think it means two things
and one of them is consistent with the
interpretation presented and one of them
isn't okay
um so if you imagine a system that will
only accept
answers that don't upend what it finds
sacred
right then it will essentially
filter the world of potential candidates
for only those
that are consistent and therefore you
will get this amazing bias it's not like
do you want you want zach to be showing
this yeah zach would you put it back up
so um all of these candidates in the
upper right hand
quadrant are effectively in the upper
hand right hand quadrant
after we know of them and after they
have ascended to a point of seriousness
in these races and so
in some sense that is you are seeing the
validation
of the duopoly there and it is not
surprising that the duopoly favors
uh authoritarian measures and is far
right leaning right
that's that's it's it's bias um so
on the one hand this is a filter of
individuals
that part would correctly reflect their
position here
but then the other part which is going
to be very hard to disentangle from this
is that their tendency to say things
that allow them to move into the next
round to live to fight another day
politically
means that they may uh not tell us what
they really think you know is bernie
sanders
really that close to the actual center
you know by some measures yes this is
why i mean that's why i read part of
their answer to the question about how
it is that they
place the can the the politicians that
they do on these graphs or they do
uh which is that they use actions
whenever they can voting records and
such
right so not not just words but if if
it's words it work it's words that have
something demonstrating skin in the game
behind them right
so the real question i think people
should be asking themselves
is if you take this test and you don't
come out in that upper right hand
quadrant and then you imagine well were
i to enter
the political landscape how how far in
that direction would i find myself
moved that's a really important question
and the fact that you would find
yourself moved at all
is really the hidden message here yeah
right the fact that our system just
simply refuses to accept
anything um of uh a different type
right that it systematically
marginalizes things in the lower
uh left-hand quadrant on the lower right
uh
yeah i would say it does though there is
a well no i guess i guess it does
systematically
marginalize both differently and you
know according to this we have no one in
the upper left now you know you you and
i would argue and i think
i think that most people would argue
given the description of what this is
trying to
describe yeah that we should be
minimizing anyone in the upper half
of this of this at all and so when i say
there's no one here in the upper left
it's not that i wish that there was
it's that i wish that there you know all
of those people in the upper right
quadrant
were down in the lower lower half and
frankly if they were all in the lower
right
we would have a much more fair and just
world even though
you and i are both pretty far over left
in that lower left quadrant
yeah um i would agree and i you know one
of the critiques that has been leveled
is that nobody will place themselves in
the upper part of this
this graph right now they will
accidentally by answering the questions
honestly but there's something
uh stigmatizing about the label
authoritarian um whereas
libertarian small l at least is not
stigmatizing yeah
um but i will also say you know in some
sense the upper left-hand
quadrant is in the street rebelling
um in a very frightening way but
wokeness
is unrepresented on this graph with
respect to modern
politicians though many have uh paid lip
service to it
um and so there's a question about
oh i also got mao and stalin and and and
shay guevara and such in the upper left
historically oh
historically yes modern times no
and you know we're seeing a resurgence
of this which is frightening right
because of
where all of those examples point but
the other thing i wanted to point out
and i wish i wish we had this paper but
a couple years back there was a paper
that suggested that authoritarianism was
actually a personality type and that
many of those
that we find on the authoritarian left
actually would be just as happy on the
authoritarian right if the winds were
blowing the other way well we talked
about
one piece of research that came out um a
number of episodes ago
that was not from a couple years ago but
more but more recent
we specifically talked about um such
such a piece of research
it's possible i'm misremembering when it
when it came out but in any
case um it is worth
considering where you would where you
would find yourself in the absence of
these other influences
what motivates you to be there um
you know in other words there's a lot of
uh
self-serving economic conservatism
in the upper right-hand quadrant whereas
ideological economic conservatives often
find themselves in the lower right hand
quadrant in other words it's a it's an
actual
belief that if we just simply clear the
decks of obstacles
people will find their way to success
and it fixes problems yeah
you know and it's not that there's no
truth in that but it's far from a
complete solution as
as you and i would see it now this is
this is verificationist i think but i
find it
interesting that the characters that i
have the most
strong visceral reaction to are are very
far over
right and the two that strike me
particularly um even farther right the
trump on here
are bloomberg and inslee and you know
bloomberg i think every american
watching at least will will recognize
who he is and at the point that he
started running late in the game um
before it looked like biden was the heir
apparent i said to you i cannot believe
that there's some chance the democrats
are going to elect
are going to nominate this guy he is he
is
so not on the left but inslee
who is uh who ran briefly is the
governor of washington state
and pretends to be pretends to be
interested in the climate
you know that's like that's his issue
and so it would seem
like you know good environmentally
interested people like us would be in
support of him but he is
at best a stuffed shirt and it wears to
completely
uh a completely corrupt frankly
caricature of a politician he's just
he's he's inept
yeah in some ways he um he is
the same level of emptiness of joe biden
but he's accomplished it without the
senility which is
you know quite something yeah no it's
true um
so actually i guess that's a point in
his favor that is i disappoint his
favorites you know
so hard to do but um okay so this
actually points
to another odd anomaly that happened
this week in the wall street journal
actually okay
i don't know you and i have not talked
about it but okay you may have seen it
where the wall street journal published
an editorial an op-ed
um decrying the lack of
honest liberals fighting a back against
uh the woke revolution oh yeah you see
did you see this
yeah i i tweeted about it uh just jason
stanley
jason still no no no no no no no no it
was uh not no
sorry that's totally wrong um i'll look
into it as you talk
rightly maybe um in any case uh
this was an amazing error
because the wall street journal
has been exceptional in publishing a
great
many jason riley jason reilly uh
publishing a great many
honest liberals who have pushed back
against woke-ism it's almost a singular
exception in this regard they've
published you they've published me peter
pagozian
they've discussed jonathan height
they've published john mcwarder
they've interviewed greg lukianov so
there's this long list of people and
somehow
either the wall street journal opinion
page
decided to ignore their own history of
publishing these people or they forgot
yeah so the quote the quote that i
pulled from the piece was
there is no shortage of conservatives
willing to push back against this
pernicious nonsense but where have the
honest liberals gone
and to some degree and this is what you
know this is what i said online
we're told in part what you're seeing if
you're on the right and you think that
no one on the left is
is speaking to this um like partially
it's just it's a it's a disingenuous and
a dishonest assessment coming out of the
wall street journal
for precisely the reasons that you say
um but in part we are told that our very
criticism of this ideology
proves that we're on the right right so
it's
it there's no there's no winning there's
no being able to continue to claim that
you're on the left if you're critiquing
the really horrifying ideology that is
emerging from the left
and that makes it even easier for
everyone from you know
uh journalists who are being uh who are
being published in the wall street
journal
to just you sort of rank and file uh
people on the street who have
either a lifetime of voting um on the
right and of being conservatives
or have moved from the left to right
over time and anyone
who moved after them i find they want to
point a finger and say where were you
how did you not see this until i saw
this
and the fact is that we you know we
should all be interested in everyone's
eyes being open to whatever is true
at the moment some of what is true is
some very scary stuff going on
on um on the far left
and you know there's a lot of stuff
going on across the political spectrum
but the idea that you aren't welcome
unless you arrived at the revelation at
the same moment that i did
that's that's not going to end well yeah
it's
uh it's crazy um and it speaks to
a you know you and i talk about the fact
that
analysis is very important to get right
but that what moves people
is narrative but the problem with that
is it also means that
narrative control is effectively the
ability to overwrite
analysis and so yeah um what's happening
here
is that we you know it's like we are
vampires who do not reflect in the
mirror
right the narrative is that there are no
liberals
pushing back that conservatism is the
bulwark that will stop this thing
right liberals are completely absent
from the fight and it's
total nonsense right and you know back
in the
early days of idw you know
we we just watched this unfold in every
major publication where all sorts of
liberals you know joe rogan uh sam
harris you and me eric
all of these people were just simply
portrayed as on the right because it was
necessary to the narrative that we'd be
on the right even though
christina summers christina sure
and the um you know the answer is
actually things like the political
compass test are very useful because you
can go and check you just
deliver you know your honest answers and
see where you come out so
it does require that you're honest
because presumably the test is gameable
if you're trying to game it sure
you can spot questions that would move
you one direction or another but if you
answer it honestly you can find out yeah
um
but okay so um all right is that as far
as we want to go political compass-wise
sure
all right what should we do next as you
like we can we can go into complex
systems let's
let's do complex systems and we have two
topics in this neighborhood
you want to start uh fully biological
sure
all right let's do it let's do it okay
so there
is uh a a structure
i will say for the moment in
boy i didn't look it up i want to say
certainly all tetrapods and i guess
probably all chordates
uh called mesentery which is sort of
this as as someone who used to teach
comparative anatomy labs where we
dissected sharks and cats or sharks and
salamanders depending on what was
available that
that quarter um it's the sort of
when you when you do visceral anatomy
and you open up the the
peritoneal cavity of of an animal
you find that basically all of the
organs of the abdominal cavity are
suspended in this sort of vague
transparent membrane uh depending on the
animal you can tell that there's
actually functional stuff inside that
membrane
sometimes it's it's quite fat especially
if you and the animal itself
the cat that you're dissecting is
actually quite fat um almost always that
mesentery has a lot of fat in it as well
um but really at the point that i was
learning my comparative anatomy in order
to teach it in the 90s in grad school
and
every time i looked into it before i
would teach it again every i don't know
three years or so because it wasn't my
main
main gig at all um as a as a professor
um it was really it was sort of this an
aside like you're going to have to get
through it
um or you're gonna you're gonna see it
and um
basically all the stuff in that cavity
that you're interested in you know the
stuff that you're interested in the
small intestine the large intestine the
stomach etc
um is suspended in this mesentery but
that's kind of it like that that's the
story and
um here's a a more formal definition of
what it is
from a paper that just came out is it's
the collection of tissues that supports
the development of all abdominal
digestive organs and that maintains
these in systemic continuity in
adulthood so that's written as sort of
biolog
biology ease but it's consistent with
it's like
you know what what is it like you know
it when you see it and you definitely
like you you did this
you you did comparative anatomy with
with me once or twice maybe
but we have now in the last couple of
years evidence that it has a single
origin
um developmentally and embryologically
embryologically exactly it has a single
origin
and that it retains a single form and
that has led to calls for it to be
labeled an an organ and
so one of the things that is
one of the sets of things that we are
now understanding about mesentery is
there and again i'm just going to quote
from this coffee at all 2020 paper
that the functions of mesentery are
underpinned by quote extensive gene and
protein expression over 50 cytokines
are produced in the mesentery these
include ghrelin
not going to be able to pronounce most
of these adiponectin resistant
adipophylline and many others cellular
activities are supported by molecular
activities
a large number of enzymes are produced
by the mesentery and it is not known if
these in conjunction with surface
receptors
subserve specialized or general
functions or both
so that both has a lot of information in
it most of which
most listeners won't have any particular
association with
but it points to oh my god the mesentery
which we thought was
not much just something you kind of cut
through when you're trying to get to the
stuff that you're trying to get to
actually is this font of molecular
enzymatic cellular functionality
that we didn't know as recently as 10
years ago
so how does this this traditional
understanding of mesentery which as long
as 100 years ago there were a couple of
doctors saying
you know the definition of mesentery is
going to prevent us
from understanding what it actually is
so that's that's very insightful right
that our debt once we have these
definitions in place
we often cannot go beyond them
and see what is actually true of them so
one more cat in my way here
one more quote if i can find it here
from this paper
is all abdominal digestive organs are
directly connected to a single mesentery
this means that the mesentery provides a
linkage mechanism between abdominal
digestive organs
in addition it collectively links all
these organs to the body
a linkage mechanism is an essential
component of any functional system
the elements of a system cannot function
in concert unless they are connected
the mesentery is the anatomical platform
in which all abdominal digestive organs
are integrated
in the systems that collectively
generate the human body
integration commences or ends at a
histological level in the digestive
organ itself
in the mesentery integration is
concentrated into prominent lymphatic
vascular and neurological elements the
mesentery can thus be compared with a
biological circuit board
by which digestive organs are integrated
in the body unless we understand the
mesentery we cannot hope to have a
complete understanding
of the mechanism by which the human body
works
so that to me is a perfect encapsulation
of the failure of reductionism in
modern medicine to and and biology to
understand what a system is
it's it reflects the hubris of uh of
of humanity in imagining that we can
walk in
uh immediately categorize a few aspects
of a system
and try to control it we cannot fully
control a complex system like this
and by imagining that we can we actually
walk ourselves into dead ends
intellectual
and clinical dead ends that are going to
have really dire health effects
and one more thing um before i stop
talking here so this
reminds me very much of uh the thinking
on fascia
as well so fascia um for for people who
are
interested in in fitness or have ever
had to go to pt
of late or are athletes that you'll
probably be familiar at this point with
the term fascia or
myofascial or myofascial release
techniques
so fascia is the very effectively the
very thin layer of muscle that lies
between the skin
and the skeletal muscle and skeletal
muscle is when you do dissections
really easy to see it has clear origin
and insertion points
um and you can you know you can point to
uh what it must do
based on where it is and what it's
attached to whereas fascia is this
set of or you know maybe single origin
of sheaths
that are wrapping the body wrapping all
aspects of the body and similarly
to mesentery at the point i was learning
my
dissections in the 90s on vertebrates
we were told just go right through the
fascia it's not really a thing you know
it doesn't it doesn't really matter
and of course it absolutely does so the
anti-fascia people were just dead wrong
is that your point is that it was all a
setup
all right so yeah this is interesting
and you know how many times are we going
to make this
mistake in various different places
right you know we're going to make it
every time
uh junk dna yes we have dna which is not
junk if it doesn't code for genes it
must not do anything right oops that's
90
of the genome right uh we've got
uh so-called vestigial organs like the
appendix
and like um the uh
the tonsils um yep we've got
uh yeah we've got a whole list of places
where we have decided that because we
didn't know exactly what something was
that it was actually some sort of
error of evolution and of course that's
essentially never going to be the case
let me just say a word about vestigial
because i actually evoked a vestigiality
in
in a tweet this week i talked about the
vestigial wings of flightless birds and
compared them to the vestigial morals
and intellects of modern politicians
uh because it amused me to do so um
after the
vice presidential debate this week um
but obviously the wings of penguins for
instance while
vestigial with reference to their
ability to allow the bird to fly
are used to allow the penguins to
effectively fly through water
and so vestigiality the term vestigial
is
kind of like the word weed and we've
talked about the word weed before on
this podcast
these vestigial and weed are actually
are actually human constructs right like
so and yeah you don't you don't totally
like this this construction so
um the way that when we call something
vestigial
it is very often a description of our
failure to understand
what it is and what we call something a
weed it is a reflection
of our desire for whether or not it
should be in the landscape or not right
so
uh just a reminder for people i argued
that
weeds are botanical noise that the
signal is what you're trying to grow in
your garden and the weeds are the
um the things that grow of their own
accord
um but in this case i don't i don't
like that because as you know i tend to
garden by um competing on behalf of the
native plants that i like
sure right no and then this is this is
the right way to think about
gardening but nonetheless you're
competing on behalf of certain plants
that are the signal and the weeds are
the ones that
you spend most of your time fighting but
in any case
the um term vestigial has a legitimate
use but i would argue in the case of
anything
truly vestigial it is also in the
process of disappearing
right now it may be a very long period
over which it is disappearing but for
example the
limbs of snakes there are
some basil snakes that have some remnant
limbs that are presumably i mean they
may have adopted a function maybe they
have stuck around and is it pythons
it's it's the boweds at the at the base
of the snake tree no one has
they don't have retain any of the
pectoral girdle or limbs but they have
early in development um a tiny pelvic
girdle and just the tiny rudiments of
femurs
right and we have uh webbing in our
fingers that disappears by apoptosis so
that is presumably vestigial or maybe
it's just structural
in other words it may be necessary to
have that webbing in order to make
fingers and
but anyway there's a distinction between
things that are
continuing to exist not disappearing
like the appendix and the tonsils
that have a function we just haven't
found it and so it's sort of we kind of
have in both those cases
but just most people don't know them but
for the long history
of medical science we didn't know what
it was and so we assumed it didn't have
one which
never made any evolutionary sense so
anyway we've got to distinguish between
those things
all right um is there more oh so let's
just
cap this off the argument here is that
this is an
organ and it is an organ in the sense
that it functions like one
it is disgusting it's got a single
origin distinct from most organs in this
do all organs have a single origin that
seems to be
the consensus and of course the the term
organ
is itself a human construct right so you
know does
does does the category organ have a
biologically meaningful reality i don't
know
but part of the reason that the
mesentery is now being reclassified as
an organ
is because it um has been found to have
a single developmental embryological
origin
right i'm just wondering whether that's
really a category that we already adhere
to maybe it is
yeah i mean i think i mean of course it
depends on how
it's fractal right it depends on how far
you go in so if you're looking you know
single embryological origin are you
talking about just like the three very
pyramidal
layers of endoderm music ectoderm you
know which case okay skin has a single
origin
but it's you know it's all over the body
so
it's it's tough to do right yeah well
and you know so
it's a very fascinating subject actually
embryology is one of those places
that in my opinion was kind of a dormant
science uh when we were in college it
wasn't you know it was
very empirical didn't have a theoretical
underpinning that was very deep there
had been some very powerful early work
where people had
grafted uh parts of chicken embryos onto
each other to see
what it changed and some of the earliest
genetic work was done by embryologists
right the let's beam in a mangle and
such
right yeah but it went through this
period where we i don't think we were
learning very much because we didn't
have the theoretical grounding and then
the so-called evo devo developmental
evolutionary science which
uh has a a large
it unearthed a large number of what are
called epigenetic factors which
in this case means these molecular
factors that adjust what genes are being
transcribed
um so anyway that's a large part of the
content of the genome that doesn't code
for proteins that was long dismissed as
junk but anyway um that field
really came alive and is now one of the
most vibrant
fields in embryology in biology wow evo
i because it now does have a deep
theoretical
grounding but one of the interesting
things that you don't really
anticipate till you see it is that a
developing
body a developing vertebrate the cells
you know each you know how you start out
with one cell and then each
cell you know is a descendant in some
line and at some point it starts
differentiating and so you're in some
line that ultimately leads
you know to an eye and several other
things but um
but in any case there are multiple
processes interacting one is the sort of
counter where the cell knows how many
you know steps down the line it is and
so it becomes more and more specific
with respect to what it does as it goes
down that line
but it also by touching other tissue is
induced to produce new kinds of
structures and so
um it is possible so there's clock and
there's induction and those are two
different processes right
and so you could get for example the
same kind of clock exactly
um you could get the same kind of tissue
produced by two different
origins because basically the real
question is to be a kind of tissue you
will encode a certain subset of genes
and you can be instructed to do that
from two different starting points
yeah so anyway well i wonder actually
boy i think i'm gonna get it wrong but
is it maybe the pancreas
maybe that has both an anterior and a
posterior
portion that are actually actually have
different embryologic
origins and so i think as a result boy
please correct me if i'm wrong and i'll
try to figure out if i am
but one one of these organs that shows
up generally
in our viscera i believe has um
at least different origins in time and i
think actually in place with regard to
embryology and then later comes together
to fuse and appears to be a single organ
but actually really is not
so that would be the perfect answer to
my question i would expect actually this
happens in multiple places but maybe not
um and maybe maybe there's a reason it
doesn't in other words maybe
uh composite organs are more vulnerable
to developmental screw-ups or something
like that who knows
and you know and and you know how how do
you get cellular policing of the borders
as they fuse
and that's there's going to be some
challenge there that you wouldn't have
in a single origin organ
yeah you're certainly going to get a um
a
increase in the potential for mismatches
yeah all right so are we there with
respect to mesentery yeah i just uh
just you know once again the
reductionism with which we often
approach complex systems and i think
this this is a place where conservatives
are much more likely
uh to uh engage in imagining that they
can control
that you can control a system and you
know control nature control the body
control you know whatever it is
and it's a mistake and it almost always
results
in um wrong understandings and missed
opportunities to actually generate
better you know health well-being
whatever it is depending on the system
you're looking at
so if you're keeping track pluto is not
a planet
mesentery is an organ the appendix is
not vestigial and junk dna does a lot of
really cool stuff
yeah i wish you hadn't put pluto on that
list all right i'm taking pluto off the
list
even though it was the taking it off the
list that put it on this list
all right so are we there we're there
all right so uh we had another topic
in the realm of complex systems which i
want to try to set in motion correctly
this time since i screwed it up badly
in the last instance i don't think
that's true um
we were speaking and don't go
fleeing from your seats as i raised this
issue we were speaking of
a certain set of technical failures that
happen in our system
while portland was inundated by smoke
from our
fires and i set this in motion as a
discussion
of tech which is stupid you don't care
about the tech i don't care very much
about the tech
i care about it in as much as it allows
us to do the podcast and not much beyond
that however
the tech allows us to understand
how you can dive into
a complex system that you will by
definition not know very much about
and make progress with respect to
understanding how it works
now i want to catch people up to where
we were because some really interesting
things came to light
after our last discussion on the podcast
about this topic so
you will recall we had a problem where
five
cameras of several different kinds began
to screw up in
almost the identical way where they
would fail to send signal to the
computer
and there would be a drop the
problem was that zach and i spent many
hours testing
every conceivable reason that our system
could be failing and we falsified
virtually
every hypothesis that was available to
us the only one left over
was interference but there was no
obvious source for the interference
and so we were puzzling over what could
possibly be interfering
with the cameras now we hypothesize that
it might be
radiation liberated by the fires
radiation that might have been lodged in
those forests
through nuclear meltdowns in fukushima
the fallout did fall in the pacific
northwest got incorporated into the
trees when the trees burned it got
liberated
and maybe those radioactive decay events
and the smoke around
us were interfering with the cameras
that was the hypothesis on the table
and it was the only thing that seemed to
explain it many of you
did some calculations on the actual
errors and you told us
that you believed that it was a mismatch
that something had
uh adjusted the frame rate of the
cameras relative to the computer so they
were slightly off because the
drops were regular right
and we falsified that hypothesis because
first of all nothing in the settings had
changed second of all when the smoke
went away the problem cured itself
without us
resetting anything and we could swap in
a totally different computer
and the problems still happen so there
was no place for a mismatch to have
gotten in the system and it wouldn't
have cured itself if it had been one
however there was something important in
that observation
what emerged as a result of this
discussion
was something we did not anticipate
which does actually
involve radiation but not in the way
that we had proposed it
so the observation is that there are
many devices as a result of the pressure
to miniaturize components the
quartz crystals that used to be
regularly used to create a
time signal in things like watches and
computers
have been replaced by a different kind
of component that i'd never heard of
called
mems m-e-m-s and these components
keep time in a different way it's not a
quartz crystal it's actually
something like a tuning fork a nano
scale
tuning fork embedded in a little chip
and you realize this sounds completely
implausible hey zach
you want to put that electron micrograph
up
okay so here is an electron micrograph
of the inside of a mems
chip which is now the time keeper on
many
electronics that have had pressure to be
shrunk down to a smaller size
um now is there can you point to
the tuning fork is it the sort of the
ends uh i believe
yeah i believe it is the end and you
kind of have two railway lines
but you know i'm no expert on this thing
and in fact this micrograph
comes from the guy whose video uh
alerted me to this um who actually took
a chip and basically sanded it down
one layer at a time to reveal how it
worked
and so he happened to have an electron
microscope and he sanded it down one
more
layer at a time and anyway to make a
long story short
these chips have to be made in such a
way that leaves the tuning fork
able to vibrate right but in order to
build them
up they have to have
you may have encountered in 3d printing
sometimes a part
has extra stuff that needs to be printed
in order to support some piece and then
that stuff gets cut out
so it has some of that they dissolve
away something that would interfere with
the functioning of these tuning forks
but to make a long story short that
means
that these chips are permeable
to very tiny molecules
and what appears to have happened is
helium is small enough to invade these
chips which was discovered
when a set of
i believe it was iphones that were in
proximity to
an mri machine suddenly all died
right the mri machine involves a certain
amount of helium
and so the long and short of this story
so i
i know where this is going but i have
not yet heard in your story
how helium gets into our story
okay so first of all we don't know the
answer there are two possible ways
but helium is very light it tends to
uh rise in the atmosphere so there's not
a lot of it down here on earth
that which is down here on earth is all
the result of
radioactive decay that is to say heavier
elements decay
into lighter elements and one of them is
very frequently helium so
uranium decay creates helium okay
so the among other things yes among
other things right
helium is one of the things it creates
so the
emerging hypothesis here is that
radioactive decay
of one kind or another and there are two
possible sources in this case
liberated helium which was trapped in
our sealed up house
and that helium invaded these chips
causing them to vibrate at a different
rate in the same way that helium causes
your vocal cords to vibrate
at a different rate if you inhale it now
if
our house was really so well sealed that
it trapped helium
uh i mean it can't have been we had we
had air exchange
we did so a it takes very little helium
to do this you would think it takes a
lot it takes very little
okay so okay let's talk a little bit
about the two possible sources of the
helium
one is radioactivity in the smoke and
there is radioactivity in the smoke
irrespective of whether
there have been meltdowns meltdowns
could exacerbate it
but it could be that a certain amount of
helium was getting into the house
where a certain amount of uh uranium was
getting into the house
decaying liberating helium which invaded
the chips which caused them to vibrate
very slightly wrong
which is the reason that people
calculated that there was a frame rate
problem
that didn't involve us miss setting
something or resetting it
it involved the chips vibrating at just
the wrong frequency so that they
regularly hiccuped right so smoke is one
uh way and the other way is that and
this is plausible here in portland
there is enough uranium in our rocks
that it could
have it could be decaying all the time
underneath the building
and something about our behavior in the
circumstance
resulted in it being trapped now i think
that's unlikely
i would lean strongly against that
hypothesis because in the winter we
don't have this phenomenon
it was smoke related and so here's what
i think happened
this studio is over the garage
right the garage was regularly opened
and invaded by smoke
during the event so we open the garage
smoke floods in close the garage
whatever decay happens happens
helium migrates up through the floor of
the studio
messes up the cameras lo and behold when
the smoke goes away problem clears
up so
the long and short of this and um you
know
heather and i were both a little bit
thrown by people not being
some people not being so interested in
this discussion because to us this is
just a complex system and it gives you
know it's a
great place to train your brain well so
what i will say is you're now talking
about our conversation about this
whatever it was two three
episodes ago right yeah um i
am less driven to be thinking about and
interested in
uh hypotheses about complex systems that
are entirely abiotic
you know that's that's a fairly gender
typical interest actually right you know
i'm more interested in the
not so much the people but the but the
but the non-human animal stuff
and uh and you know those of you with y
chromosomes are more likely to be more
interested in the stuff that are there
more things even you know
even a biologist um so the particulars
don't really intrigue me i don't spend
time at night thinking about them but i
do spend time at night thinking about
things like mesentery so that's my
that's my weird you know interests um
but the conversation that we had uh
whatever it was two three four episodes
ago
struck me as exactly the kind of
conversation regardless of the
particular topic
uh that we would be able to have in
long-term discussion with students in
our classrooms
because we were exploring ideas
hypotheses predictions
and you know that's that's the thing
that i hope for us to be able to do more
of here
as when if
the world in any way normalizes and uh
we can look forward to
uh to actually trying to build something
new and good as opposed to constantly
feeling like
what's going to happen next well i agree
with this of course i would just add
one thing on top of it which is
you know there's a question of where you
are going to train your mind
to do certain things and the
problem with biology is
the there's almost nothing in biology so
simple that you can really understand it
fully
and that means that we're all dropped in
at some level and we have a very scatter
shot
understanding of some things and black
boxes elsewhere and then there are
things that are black boxes for everyone
and that's not a great place to train
yourself to do the work that makes you a
really
good biologist so one of the things i
discovered
in my dissertation work which was on
biological trade-offs that was what i
ended up
doing my dissertation on was that the
things that i had
gotten involved in that were complex but
not
very complex that i was involved in for
reasons that had nothing to do with
biology or theory or anything
turned out to be very useful models so
things like the evolution of the bicycle
a flight of of human flight right yeah
so
aviation turns out airplanes are simpler
than you think and there's certain
aspects in which they mirror biological
processes
i mean not accidentally in fact the
wright brothers were inspired by the
flight of birds
and the flight of toys that mimic birds
and things like this
but you know cameras also which have now
gotten so freaking
complicated that you can't necessarily
understand them in detail but
there was something about learning to
shoot
uh a you know a manual camera
that has trade-offs written into them in
a way that they become second nature to
you
so you know one of the things that uh i
ended up realizing in my dissertation
work was that when we say trade-off we
mean one of two different things and one
and this is very well um
this is very well mirrored in in cameras
so for example a bigger lens collects
more light right that's an inescapable
relationship right um on the other hand
if you have an amount of light coming
into the camera and that's
proper to make a good exposure you can
play games
with you know increasing the shutter
speed um
and increasing the size of the aperture
uh in order to you know either freeze
motion
or get greater depth of field but you're
stuck in this trade-off world until you
can supplement the light at which point
the trade-off
seems to vanish right you can get
shorter shutter speeds
and smaller aperture at the same time so
anyway
i just thought it was a good discussion
and that what i
what i think we both hope people will
get from this
is that any system that is uh
that you can sort out through
hypothetical deductive method is a good
place to train your mind to think about
these things
absolutely and i'm reminded in your
discussion of cameras
you know what you say about cameras now
being so complicated that it's really
hard to do it but when you have a
somewhat simpler you know somewhat less
electronically based camera
um another thing that you would do
especially when you're in the field for
instance in panama
is if something stopped working
including you know you became the guy
that other people when their stuff
stopped working they would bring it to
you
and um you would take it apart and you
would put it back together and very
often
it would work and sometimes it wouldn't
but you would have learned something and
you might have
saved you know the day for them and
their research um
cars are the same way you you weren't
you know a particularly
you know car interested guy nor was nor
was i at all
um but cars also have become so
complicated that people can't really
learn to work on their own modern cars
but any car from
i don't know any car from probably the
90s or mid 90s or earlier
almost you should be able to work on to
some degree and and
learn and learn something real about
the universe that way and so i just want
to pitch as i have before
um this book shop class as soul craft by
matthew crawford
um who is a you know phd
in economics from the chicago school
from university of chicago
who left his life as a i don't know some
kind of
talking head consultant inside the
beltway i think
um to open up a vintage motorcycle
repair shop in virginia where he finds
that his life has much more meaning
because he's actually solving um he's
actually solving
real problems you know problems come to
him that are
um maybe amorphous maybe not clear but
clearly there's a problem at the point
that the motorcycle doesn't run
for instance to use just the easiest
example and if he makes it run he has
solved it
so there are real problems affecting
real people that's one aspect of it
but maybe more interesting from my
perspective is it
you know that you are training your mind
and honing
your not just your intuition but your
insight and your analysis
uh when you work on such a system and
make it better as a result
yeah absolutely um i want to adjust
one thing you can work on a modern car
and you can
you know play these games with the
modern camera the problem is that the
fraction
that is in the black box has gotten so
great that you are
you know you are just a consumer of the
information
of the black box that doesn't mean that
there aren't other things yeah
if i can give one the same thing has
happened to just two statistics
you know the way that i taught
statistics which i did every time i
taught animal behavior was
from the ground up and i didn't let
students
use the tests that they did not have a
real solid understanding of
the assumptions that went into them and
you know if there was
a chance at all that they could use a
chi square which there's a fairly
limited number of questions that you can
use a chi square on
but a goodness of fit test like that you
can literally do by hand
all you need is the one chart of
critical values to compare your answer
to and then you know whether or not
you've got a result that
um is unlikely to have happened by
chance and it's just so empowering not
to have fed your
hard-earned data that you collected
after you imagined what the hypothesis
was the predictions were in the
experimental design where and everything
to not feed that into the black box that
is sas or you know or
you know spss or whatever your physical
program is are
and have it spit something out go like
well i guess so
i guess the people who wrote the
software know what they're doing so it
speaks to two different kinds of
empowerment right
one is how well does your brain work how
well
programmed and primed is it based on
your ability to actually run a test that
you understand
but from the point of view of the
careerist the ability to throw stuff
into a program and try different tests
until something statistically
significant pops out
and have no you know it's you know
curious if you broke the assumptions of
the test
well it's not who cares it's i didn't
know
right and so the point is where did the
replication crisis came from
it came from a lot of people using very
powerful software that was all black
boxed to them
in order to get results that were flashy
most of which were wrong
almost no biologist i've talked to
understands the statistics that they use
in their published work
right and so that has been
a disaster and it is the result of a
complex a semi-complex system that the
people
navigating it don't know anything about
so i wanted to point out um
a couple of things about what happened
as these cameras so my first camera was
a manual
canon i was lucky enough my dad gave me
an f1 which was this very high quality
but ancient
uh manual camera and you could
understand fully how it worked right
at the point that digital cameras took
over
it changed things so we used to have two
parameters that we would play off
against each other right you had shutter
speed and you had
aperture or the lens opening at the
point that digital cameras
became the norm suddenly you had a third
but
it took me a long time to even realize
that i had a third the third being
sensitivity of the sensor right because
it used to be that you would load your
camera with a kind of film you'd load it
with
iso 100 or 400 or 800 or something and
then you were just stuck with it and so
you were playing this trade-off game
in a world where the sentence was vsa
right what film was asa film was asa
then it became iso and then that got
transported onto these
sensors but the whole point is my mind
was built around a world
of shutter speed and aperture in which i
had before i ever you know
walked out the door i had set in motion
the
sensitivity and that was a fixed
parameter so sometimes i would carry two
cameras
to have two different speed films
because it was just
so fixed so i mean i think i think
you're not
quite doing yourself a service here i
mean i know from us having packed
carefully you know many you know dozens
of rolls of film packed them in these
lead bags so that they could go through
airport security if they refused to let
us have them hand checked and all of
this
um that we would always travel with um
everything ranging from 64 to 1600
uh when we were when we were shooting
film in the 90s when we were in grad
school
and um it's not that you weren't
constantly thinking about sensitivity
it's that once you had a roll of 36
um loaded you couldn't do anything about
it right once once you were
faced with the question of the the the
module that operates in the mind has
this thing as a fixed parameter and it
knows very well how sensitive the film
in that
camera body is but it's just not it's
not an option to play with it
right and so the thing is at the point
that you can play with that parameter
very often what you want to do is pick
your ideal shutter speed pick your
ideal aperture and then borrow from iso
so it's a whole different mindset that
takes you a while to get used to and now
we're getting into this
new realm so this keeps happening right
so um
digital did this then mirrorless changes
a bunch of bunch of things where
suddenly you know it used to be that you
would hit a button in order to see what
your depth of field looked like and the
lens would stop down and you could see
what was going to be in focus
where is that gone well you don't need
it because now the viewfinder has that
built in you're just seeing it all the
time yeah right
so you've got to now erase that thing to
wonder about because you're
it's you know it's going to be automatic
to photographers who learn on something
like that
and now we have algorithms that denoise
things so now you can start borrowing in
a way that doesn't have a cost so anyway
it's
it's a whole series it's it's becoming
more biological and therefore maybe less
useful
as a model um
but more biological i don't know i don't
think so
um i'd say if anything it's less
here's what i mean by more biological
biology is so complex
right the number of ways in which um
parameters can be made to interact the
way it
you know the trade-offs are inherent on
the inside but they can
be obscured by the complexity of the
situation
um the more complex an object is the
more like biology it is and therefore
my whole point about you know a simple
camera is a good way to train your brain
to think about trade-offs becomes less
and less true i would i would then not
say more biological it's you know the
complexity has increased
and the places where the black boxes
exist and you have no way to get in as a
end user of the product have increased
but that doesn't
mean that it's like biology no i don't
mean it's like biology i mean
it is analogous to biology in the sense
that there's too much black box
for you to be sure what you're seeing
yep
all right uh well i would like to share
to um sort of go back to
not exactly what we were talking about
with the political compass test but
um some of what we've talked about a lot
and we will return to where we are
hearing so many
so many horror stories of what people
are experiencing in their workplaces
and in the schools their children are in
uh
and on campuses on college campuses
and many episodes ago i had said
that we might do an episode devoted to
school and i frankly i'm just
so drowning in all of the stories and
evidence of things gone so awry across
so many domains that i'm not even sure
where
where to start with that so this is you
know this is obviously not that episode
but i wanted to share a little bit
of an essay from alexander silchnetson
that he wrote in 1974 called live not by
lies
hat tip to barry weiss uh for posting
this i think on
on twitter and and leading me down down
this little
rabbit hole into a rabbit warren uh so
for those for those who don't know
i'm not going to read the whole essay
but we'll post it in the um probably the
video description so that you can
find the whole thing but again it's
called live not by lies
uh social nets and fought for the red
army for russia in world war
ii uh but and you know obviously on the
side of the allies
but a critical comment about stalin in a
private letter got him sent to a soviet
gulag which is a
forced labor camp for eight years so he
he fought for the allies um he he was
one of the
millions of russian soldiers who
really substantively helped win the war
um who was then sent to a gulag for
a a critical comment that was supposed
to be private even about stalin
i personally was first made aware of
sultanates in my first quarter in
college when i was still a literature
major
and i was in a class uh devoted to
reading solchenitsen and
the works of sultanates and kundera as
well we read i don't think we read the
whole gulag archipelago selections from
it
and um he he has always struck me
as you know so many of the important
russian thinkers
have as uh pointed and careful and deep
and surprising so uh here
a a section from this live not by lies
uh essay from 1974 which i think it's
bright it's that year that he was
exiled and he lived in the u.s for many
years and then after
um after the cold war ended he ended up
moving back to the
to the so to russia i guess um
where he he died many years ago
so from the middle of this essay is the
circle closed
is there really no way out is there only
one thing left to do to wait without
taking any action
maybe something will happen by itself
but it will never happen as long as we
daily acknowledge extol and strengthen
and do not sever ourselves from the most
perceptible of its aspects
lies when violence intrudes into
peaceful life its face glows with
self-confidence as if it were carrying a
banner and shouting i am violence
run away make way for me i will crush
you but violence quickly grows
old after only a few years it loses
confidence in itself and in order to
maintain a respectable face it summons
falsehood as its ally
since violence can conceal itself with
nothing except lies and the lies can be
maintained only by violence
violence does not lay its paw on every
shoulder every day
it demands from us only obedience to
lies and daily participation in lies
and this submissiveness is the crux of
the matter the simplest and most
accessible key to our self-neglected
liberation is this
personal non-participation in lies
though lies may conceal everything
though lies may control everything we
should be obstinate about this one small
point
let them be in control but without any
help from any of us
this opens a breach in the imaginary
encirclement caused by our inaction
it is the easiest thing for us to do and
the most destructive for the lies
because when people renounce lies it
cuts short their existence
like a virus they can survive only in a
living organism
let us admit it we have not matured
enough to march into the squares and
shout the truth out loud or to express a
loud what we think
it is not necessary it's dangerous but
let us refuse to say what we do not
think
this is our path the easiest and the
most successful one which allows for
inherent well-rooted cowardice
and it's much easier it's shocking even
to say this than the sort of civil
disobedience that gandhi advocated
our path is not that of giving conscious
to support support to lies about
anything at all
and once we realize where the perimeters
of falsehood are everyone sees them in
his own way
our path is to walk away from this
gangrenous boundary
if we did not pace together the dead
bones and scales of ideology
if we did not sew together rotting rags
we would be astonished how quickly the
lies would be rendered helpless and
would subside
that which should be naked would then
really appear naked before the whole
world
so in our timidity let us make each make
a choice
whether to remain consciously a servant
of falsehood of course it is not out of
inclination but to feed one's family
that one raises one's children the
spirit of lies
or to shrug off the lies and become an
honest man worthy of respect from one's
children and contemporaries
and one final paragraph um near the end
of the
essay
and he who is not sufficiently
courageous to defend his soul
don't let him be proud of his
progressive views and don't let him
boast that he is an academician or a
people's artist or a distinguished
figure or a general
let him say to himself i'm a part of the
herd and a coward
it is all the same to me as long as i'm
fed and kept warm
wow there's so much need some for you so
i can't help but
feel that um
there's something we are so
far from a
a moment in time when it is even
conceivable
that lies wouldn't be the majority of
what we encounter
that it just seems almost an impossible
uh gap to cross well but he's not saying
do not encounter lies
he says do not acquiesce to them not do
not do not
do not intone them yourself do not
repeat them and
indeed you know yes there's a long
bulleted list in this of what
what you should do which i decided not
to read because it's fairly long but
um do not you know do not repeat them
and
when they come at you even and this is
harder do not buy your silence up here
to acquiesce to them yeah i guess i mean
i
i of course agree with this and try to
live by it
but um but nonetheless i do
i think that something having to do with
advertising
you know which has changed so much since
that was written
um has drenched us so thoroughly in lies
that we have become a nerd to them in a
new way
and um i don't know it's slightly
hopeless to
uh to imagine that we have to turn the
tide against lies in order to
to make progress well you know of course
he is
he is speaking to the lies of ascendant
or now um now enmeshed in society
ideologies
and that is that you know that's why i
read it here now right that we have
um we have lies coming from every
politician
every politician i'm quite sure of it um
but some of them
are in the moment useful to them and
don't have any
necessarily any systemic meaning to them
but when when so many people
are being asked to for instance
agree that they are racist agree that
they can't never not be racist
agree that the color of their skin makes
them responsible for the sins of their
forefathers
agree that their children are racist
agree that they have toxic masculinity
no right no that sex is not binary
that sex is not binary i mean it goes on
and on and on and on that
that talking about the reality of sex
being binary makes you a transphobe
no no it does not none of these things
are true
yes well in that context i think it's
important to recognize i'm still not
quite sure how to phrase it but
something very powerful in brett stevens
in
the new york times having um
pointed out just how broken the 1619
project is and how has been and
he was very careful about it as i think
he would have to be in order to publish
it there but
um but the duplicitous
way in which the central claim
of the 1619 project was
memory hold because it was unsustainable
that that recognition is not just
you know a massive lie of a kind that is
beginning to move civilization
but it was a massive lie in what was
known
in our lifetime as the paper of record
right
to have the paper of record whose clear
obligation is to report
to the best of its ability what has
happened and what it appears to mean
to have it dispensing lies which are
clearly ideological and
targeted at political power i mean it's
obviously not news to anyone that the
new york times is now doing that
but to see such a spectacular example
which now the new york times has been
forced to admit because
apparently it couldn't sustain the lie
is really
stunning so maybe there's hope in that
maybe
we've reached some place where
there is a limit to what one can claim
in this space and even though
it has taken many many months to reveal
the
the bankruptcy of that perspective it
has now it has now emerged that's an
important victory
yeah i i hope so um i mean i think i
guess i'm reminded
as you're talking about a i i hate going
to tweets but um
a tweet that i saw today um that i
responded to um that says
this guy i'm just i'm not don't show it
zack i'm not even gonna read the guy's
name
if you go on my twitter feed you'll see
that i quote tweeted it but um
he says a lot of mediocre white men are
obsessed with the 1619 project because
nothing that they will do in their life
will ever have the kind of
impact that um and hannah jones had and
their fragile egos can't handle it
well that's one lie and assertion and ad
hominem attack on top of another
and it's clearly about the brett
stephens piece in the new york times
about the 1619 project but
the idea that it's men who are white
who are mediocre um who are obsessed
with this project and it's because they
themselves are failures
as opposed to it's it's a lot of us
regardless of the immutable
characteristics that we were born with
who look at this project and say
actually that's just that's just a
bad piece of work that is a bad piece of
work it's bad scholarship
and it's divisive and you're lying
and we're not going to stand for it has
nothing to do with our mediocrity
no right well i would say it even goes a
step
beyond that because the whole idea of
this country can only be understood
as a from the first moment
white supremacist project leaves
no option but to dismantle it because
there's nothing to fix
right and so this lie is so pernicious
with respect to the actual nature
of this country which yes screwed up
from its first instantiation
but did aspire to something better in
fact
aspired to exactly the thing that an
honest broker
would want us now to achieve right which
is a truly equal society
so anyway it was it was absolutely
necessary to push back on this because
the basic point is
if you accept this narrative framing
then it necessitates
a massive project of undoing
that is not justified so you know this
is about power and limited resources
stupid as
your advisor's file cabinet
reminded us every time we walked into
his office that's right
um all right uh are we there yeah i
believe we are there
i think we are so i had intended to
start this hour by reminding people that
we answer
questions that you write in via super
chat uh
in the second hour i failed to but i'll
say it now
um so many questions you asked now uh we
will try to get to next hour and then
we'll start
um next hour uh we will also answer
questions that come in the super chat in
the stream for the q a which
will start in about 15 minutes we have a
private monthly q a
uh on that you can access on my patreon
there is a private discord service you
can access on either of patreons
brett runs a couple of conversations
each month
through his as well and we encourage you
to subscribe to the channel
so that so that you don't miss content
you've got at least one
other podcast darkest podcast coming up
this week and we may have a couple more
uh in the works we will definitely be
back
live a week from today maybe before then
but uh there will probably be another
dark horse podcast before that
yes i believe uh we will do one and
hopefully it will be out
shortly thereafter all right so looking
forward to all of that
um all right we will see you in 15
minutes
in the meantime be well
you